[Música]
y nuestro invitado al día es pedro
alonso escritor actor y pintor español
pedro gracias por estar con nosotros en
directo américa de france 24 un gusto
que estés aquí que tal raúl es un placer
esta es la última entrevista de todo el
periplo de estos tres días y pico que
está en el silbo y me dijeron todo es
una preparación para cuando llegues a la
entrevista con raúl ya que vengo vengo
muy enfilado vienes preparado bien es
bueno pero yo creo que estoy sudando ya
pero yo tengo aquí este esta tableta no
lo que héctor es pintor bueno digamos
que pintamos que sí y que tiene una
presencia muy muy muy importante en mi
día a día obviamente te quiero pedir
disculpas porque obviamente algo digital
temas pues obviamente es orgánico sí
pero aquí traer un lienzo pintura si es
posible entonces lo que quiero hacer
contigo si tú quieres también si te
estás a gusto es que dibujes cómo te vas
sintiendo en entrevistas y usa como que
hablando y yo vamos a estar conversando
no digamos que nos una entrevista y tú
aquí vas a estar aquí pues tienes como
toda la paleta de colores y hay
mucho
y lo voy a intentar para ir para atrás
es esto es muy bien sí igual tomas
preguntando a medida que vamos avanzando
y pareceres que dibuje las flores a tu
cara
otro objeto un lápiz o algo tener dos o
que incorpora tivo es corporativo me
intentan llevar
esas francesa sí
claro en parís el libro arranca si lo
que empieza el libro de philip o suárez
equipo pero yo hice una regresión
es una cosa un poco chocante de entrada
yo nunca había encontrado con nadie que
hacía regresiones a las vías meditativas
y tatiana me dio mucha confianza
pero yo no puede anticipar el impacto de
la regresión y en la regresión yo era
filipo un soldado romano en tiempos del
imperio que viaja a oriente conoce al
líder del grupo rebelde y le cambia la
vida o sea que
yo fui filippo en otra vida pero más
allá de que tú te creas o no o incluso
de que yo me creyese que existían el
impacto emocional la reclusión fue tan
grande que yo le di que dos años de
trabajo yo sé que por mi trabajo
personal vengo a sintiendo que esto es
una parte de un flujo que sigue
pero no tengo tampoco la convenció para
ir convencido a la gente de eso sí que
me resuena y yo vengo haciendo mi
trabajo para seguir intentando
profundizar en esa línea pero cada uno
tiene que responder lo es algo muy
íntimo claro y antes lo creías digamos
como este proceso este proceso de
regresión porque partido nunca ha tenido
una nunca ha conocido una diana para
para ti de que me haga una regresión y
yo digo primero pues creo que soy un
poco incrédulo de decir como como yo voy
a transportar una vida pasada y aseguró
que es un incrédulo el alumno nada más
verlo dije sin quererlo listo
directamente inteligente pero incrédulo
si no creo mucho entonces
explícame cómo es este proceso me
imagino que como no lo dijiste es algo
muy íntimo pero también debe ser un
proceso como de mucha meditación mucha
concentración para llegar a ver a ese
philip a
mira yo era un tipo muy mental
y tengo una parte que sigue siendo
activa me encanta el estudio me encanta
tener una charla una buena conversación
encanta aprender pero me di cuenta de
que
esa parte era una muy pequeña de lo que
yo intuía que era la totalidad y que
además no me
llevaba a un camino de salud
a los treinta y pocos tuve un colapso
durísimo profesional vital
y digamos que de alguna forma todo se me
derrumbó 34 a 33 y estoy a punto de
colapso pero no sé yo tuve un momento
fuerte fuerte lo he visto desde ahora se
empecé muy fuerte la profesión muy
fuerte yo empecé como actor me salió un
trabajo con una compañía española que
tenía mucha potencia a una prueba en
cine me dan un protagonista del otro por
esta empecé muy fuerte y luego la caída
fue terrible terrible es dura dura y
pensé que se me había pasado el tren y
empecé de cero otra vez y en ese
ejercicio
el impulso fundamental era yo quiero
sentirme bien quiero estar tranquilo
quiero disfrutar de la vida de una forma
más saludable y sentí que tenía que
quitarme las gafas que tenía hasta
entonces y crearme otras nuevas y desde
entonces me dedico a intentar como como
trabajar en un instrumental para poder
navegar de una forma más agradecida y
ahí aparecen las vías meditativas empecé
a meditar empecé a pintar
luego hace unos años apareció el
chamanismo que tengo una vertiente muy
esotérica pero no quiere decir que esa
trascendencia tenga que ser como no
claro que yo quiero recuperar la
relación con el espíritu que podría
tener una abuelita que te canta un canto
mientras te da el dulce más rico
o sea una espiritualidad alejada de las
estructuras de poder de las iglesias y
de todo pero soy una persona con una
vertiente muy espiritual si es verdad y
lo atiendo y el libro de filippo tiene
tiene algo de eso tiene algo eso pero
que tú te puedes leer como una novela
si a ti la vida te va bien y eres una
persona que viene de aquí para arriba
quién soy yo para decirte que cambies
pero yo veo que el mundo va cojo
muchísimo super inteligente que cuanto
más en cuanto mejor le va la vida en
términos de producción bien más
amargados entonces hay cosas muy
paradójicas que yo en mi trabajo
personal atiendo pero que comparto sin
afán de
demostrarle a nadie que es la verdad
bueno cada uno cada uno tiene sus
procesos y yo veo también que las
personas muy espirituales como tú que
tengo el gusto de conversar han tenido
que pasar por esa serie de procesos como
de tocar fondo digamos de alguna manera
para después encontrar realmente el
sentido de la vida que es eso estar
tranquilo estar sereno
y encontrar como algo algo más allá bien
sea una religión un proceso espiritual
lo que sea
[Música]
qué es tan difícil y cuando una persona
puede decir ya estoy cansado todo esto
quiero tirar todo y mandar toda la porra
para poder ser yo y hacer lo que
realmente a mí me apetece a mí me gusta
y ser feliz pero es que hay algo a veces
con esto de la felicidad y la felicidad
no es vivir en los mundos de yuppi no sé
ahora somos felices y todos guays y qué
bonito
la felicidad es
encontrar la manera de surfear la ola de
una manera más plena ya veces para para
ser artes que crujir antes que meterte
en el océano tiene que pasar susto pero
hay momentos en las vi en la vida en la
que de repente en la estación de que
estás conectado en el presente y tiene
flow y te sienta bien pero parece que
currárselo
el cura si somos una sociedad con una
tolerancia a la frustración muy pequeña
por media texto
y si no no está bien
entonces yo estoy intentando lo que te
decía revisitar el instrumental
para seguir creciendo y tener la
sensación de que tengo un jardín que
cada vez se parece más al jardín que yo
quiero no al que el mundo dice que debo
aspirar
qué es el éxito el éxito es que te
conozca mucha gente o el éxito es dormir
tranquilo entonces creo que dormir
que es el éxito
tener mucho o ser capaz de saborear
genuinamente un huevo frito
una ducha caliente por ejemplo caliente
el aspecto de un amigo que te respeta y
que te valore que te apoya en un momento
y te dice las cosas a la cara tienes
esos amigos yo ahora me voy a hacer una
miniserie documental que es uno de los
pasos más d
más excitantes en mi vida pero también
de más compromiso y me voy con mi amigo
con gente con la que ya ha trabajado
como como actor
con la que tengo conversaciones
que me molan y coraje me lo paso bien
el privilegio de un momento propicio
como este en el que vivo para que lo
aprovecho para hacer lo que me da la
gana claro de una forma que mezcle todo
lo que me interesa viajar mis amigos mi
novia la pintura rodar la interpretación
la escritura todo eso lo hago para que
para disfrutar de la vida y compartir si
la gente a la que le puede interesar
mientras sigo aprendiendo a disfrutar de
la vida mejor pero no soy capaz de
hacerlo todos los días yo hay 10 que
pillo el charco hay días que me equivoco
hay días que no tengo ni idea pero le
pongo mucho empeño en este momento de
todo ya tienes días de frustración
imagino que si además también pero lo
que te quería preguntar era como qué
esperas tú cuando la gente lea tu libro
que pueden sentir que pueden explorar en
el en el libro de philip o además
participaste las ilustraciones me
imagino que si las ilustraciones las
hemos firmado como mago porque ma google
me llama la atención va webs
como firmamos cuando está tiene yo
pintamos a cuatro manos le encanta
pintar
digamos está el lienzo a iván otro fin
también losa como un piano a cuatro
manos total eso lo probamos una vez en
parís fuimos a ver una exposición
una exposición de le gusta mucho que
haya le gustaba mucho y tatiana dijo
vamos a pintar tal pintó ella ya pinten
lo pusimos y al día siguiente dijo vamos
a pintar algo juntos
en modo había como dos líneas de fuerza
algo muy expresionista y luego él es muy
dibujito
el expresionismo la neofiguración por
decirlo de alguna manera ella empezaba y
yo luego dibujaba pero si ya quería
intervenir en el dibujo adelante y yo lo
sigo adelante y nos hicimos una sesión
de noche de 6 horas
y vimos lo que habíamos hecho y era
nos gusta bien pero no era ni lo que
hacía ella ni lo que hacía yo
si italia dice nos vamos a llamar mago
y firmamos como mago cuando pintamos a
cuatro manos y la productora que he
creado para rodar el documental y con la
que estamos desarrollando proyectos de
creación propia se llama mago por eso
que tan íntimo es el proceso es el
proceso de la pintura no y qué tan
diferente esa es además el proceso
literario el proceso en este caso crear
en el libro de de filippo obviamente
basado en esta regresión que tuviste a
tu vida pasada y cuál es la diferencia
con que te sentirías más cómodo también
pues mira para mí todos son mimbres del
mismo haz esto
pero
si yo no pinto no pudo rodar si yo no
pinto no puede escribir o sea que de las
herramientas de la última que
prescindiría sería de la pintura porque
me ayuda como a
concentrarme pero
sin anticipar qué es lo que va a pasar
yo a veces estoy rodando y estoy así es
que yo vi un documental
y tiro y voy a ir porque si algún día si
algún día dice en acción y no me acuerdo
de lo que tengo que hacer yo preparo
mucho
sí sí sí pero preparar mucho a lo mejor
es que pinto y pinto y pinto y mi
habitación de pintura ser oficial no
procuro trabajar desde ahí porque si no
tu cabeza quiere controlarlo todo si si
tú y yo nos dejaremos trasladados aquí
con la entrevista no papá resina yo yo
tenía de la izquierda un poco aparte
está un poco de cosas y dije ya luego a
soltarte esa es la onda la onda está
bien que tú hayas hecho el trabajo
pero que tú y yo tengamos la confianza
para para acceder a los conocidos algo
imprevisto
pero visto a tolerar no
es tu cabeza el control he visto actores
voy a hacer esto papá papá y lo hacen yo
digo ah pues está bien pero me da igual
porque te veo venir todo el rato claro
hazlo en casa y me lo mandas o sea que
le da igual lo que yo haga lo que tú
hagas lo que el equipo esté vibrando que
llueva o que haga sol porque aburrido no
por qué
la magia es lo imprevisto y yo fui
viendo en gente que te inspira
que cuando entraba en esa longitud de
onda me tocaban de una forma más fuerte
y entonces he ido buscando y aparte han
y me sienta mejor me reconforta cuando
voy a un plato y de repente digo wow si
no hubiese previsto esto que ha pasado
eso eso me mola pero pero también hace
este proceso de pintar digamos cuando
creas un personaje
actorales y que tanto te ayuda a pintar
para construir tu personaje para hacer
absolutamente todo todo este proceso
nervioso
pero no me gusta nada porque la gente
[Música]
y
más capacidad para escuchar lo que yo
estoy hablando para responderme y para
pintarme bueno
si me estás ayudando y lo digo
completamente en serio o sea no siempre
se puede ser un mes atrás pero
permitiendo jugar a esto y bueno está
respirando conmigo y estamos encontrando
el timing
estabas haciendo entre los dos ciertos
procesos es una es una pintura no a
cuatro manos a dos manos y una boca
estoy haciendo un dibujo sin que tuviera
ese luego no se parece en nada pero a lo
mejor hay algo que te hace que te
reconozcas no sé seguro
y tener ese dibujo siempre va a mejorar
como como este momento
cuando yo dibujo es una muy buena cosa
si estoy en un viaje y estoy concentrado
yo algún dibujo si vuelvo al dibujo me
acuerdo completamente del momento
lo que digo
tengo memoria muy desigual soy yo
también de repente veo un dibujo y
entonces yo me di cuenta de que ahí la
energía iba de una forma más fuerte y
ahora me gusta mucho me gusta mucho la
comunicación y se vio que hay algo que
te hace enchufarte de forma más fuerte
ahí voy no me lo planteo pero además de
este documental que dices que vas a
hacer
quisiera volver a la ocasión tienes
planes obviamente de volver a actuar o
quieres volver a hacer otra otra obra
literaria público que me retiro de la
profesión
el titular y ahí el amarillismo
vengo de rodar una peli de ciencia
ficción que acabe el domingo que se
acabe el otro día y después de la
miniserie documental rodar el spin-off
de berlín que va a ser
otro viaje potente no
d
[Música]
de mucha exposición
seguramente el año y pico más olímpico
de mi vida pero bueno lo sabía desde
hace un tiempo y digamos que me he
preparado para intentar dosificar me y
llegar vivo al final porque no es sólo
eso tiene sativa decir porque
conversando con actores como tú que tan
exhausto te puede dejar un personaje
además obviamente o sea una persona como
dice es tu metódica meticulosa que lo da
todo en un personaje que tanta energía
te puede quitar en este proceso un
personaje además cómo hacer para
explicarte para desarrollarte de un
personaje digamos lo que no quiero
hablar en esta entrevista de la casa de
papel pero personas tan fuerte y tan
icónico que te dio a conocer en todo el
mundo como berlín de la casa papel los
voy a eso porque cómo hacer para para
decir yo soy pedro alonso y no berlín
que ha costado además esto es que yo no
le puedo decir a la gente lo que puede
pensar a los gobios 100% para que si
eres tú
que es que yo ya me desvinculado de
hockey si no ni corto nada en lo
que si intento es baja a llevar una
tierra aquí contigo
e insisto a veces lo bajar bien hacerlo
bajas mal
y procuro como yo por qué porque estoy
con el libro mi parte digamos del ego la
parte de comunicación era en este
momento la idea ateo cubierta pero por
por red por devolver o restituir la
atención que me dan desde un lugar que
es que me haga sentir que la
comunicación es más valiosa es venga a
la cocina de mi casa tú me has da una
corriente de afecto vamos a intentar en
una conversación en la que tú y yo
volvamos a ser personas por igual tienes
un pelotazo como el de la casa de papel
hay algo que te despega no y eso es un
proceso que adultera la relación con lo
con lo humano
y además la gente acciones transfers
increíble con el personaje yo digo dos
más dos son cuatro
berlín
yo digo parece que va a hacer un mal día
berlín da igual lo que le digas si esa
persona está empeñada en hacer el
tránsfer da igual lo que le digas
entonces yo procuro meter zambomba para
que a mí me devuelva algo y para que al
otro le pase algo pero a veces cuando
pasa algo se lían cosas
no no no puedo hacer nada más que cuando
tengo oportunidad
bajar esa tierra pero por propia salud
personal también si nada más que que
lo que hago lo hago por razones egoístas
para sentirme para sentir más a gusto y
eso es lo que yo también trato de hacer
con mis invitados pues más allá de la
personalidad del personaje que tengo es
como hoy vamos a hablar como persona o
sea porque pero se puede no siempre es
difícil obviamente además personas que
pues no quieren no están como en ese
juego de creerse las que que más allá
del nombre una persona normal y
corriente que igual toma café en la
mañana que tiene hijos que siente
pero por eso me encanta tener este
espacio también y conocer y conversar
con personas como tú porque realmente
creo que es como también la esencia de
una entrevista y lo que también quiere
quiere ver una persona más allá más allá
del pedro alonso un personaje que
pudiese hacer y ser reconocido en una
película de una serie el ser humano que
está ahí no pero
tú y yo sabemos
lo difícil que es
[Música]
atreverse a hacer lo que uno
dice no conozco en ningún lugar del
mundo en el que yo sea realmente lo que
yo soy
pero es duro
y sin embargo cuando
pasa algo de forma genuina el retorno es
instantáneo
pero hace falta mucha atención no como
una cierta gracia un cierto talento una
cierta ligereza
que uno tiene que ejercitar bueno yo
estoy en ese empeño
[Música]
y me parece que es la mejor forma de
seguir sorprendiendo con la vida pero ya
ya sí si no hago esto creo que se acaba
mi carrera en france 24 serio y
lamentablemente tengo que tengo que
despedirte ya me están diciendo que me
extendí demasiado podemos aquí estar
horas la verdad sido un gusto un placer
haber conversar contigo haber hablado de
como como personas como seres humanos
como unas personas que se conocen en una
escena unos amigos una fiesta por
supuesto vamos a ver cómo quede ahora la
gente pues no se parece tanto no dibuja
también eso es lo que importa la cuenta
es la vibration el momento
pero de verdad muchísimas gracias no hay
tanto esta vez que pena bueno hay si ya
llegó el momento de despertar a esta
conversación porque ya tampoco me gusta
llamarlo entrevista pero ha sido un
placer de ver ha encantado no solo
contigo sino con el equipo que está
detrás de las cámaras gracias chicos si
has hecho un trabajo estupendo durante
toda esta feria del libro que hacía así
que bueno gracias a ustedes también
continúan con nosotros hay mucho más
para vella en france 24 y por supuesto
en directo américa continúa con nosotros